que le meilleur gagne plus voici les 200
candidats qui sont venus jouer avec
Nagui
vous serez en tête à tête pour une
troisième manche nouvelle dans cette
émission et enfin une fois que vous
aurez gagné ce tête à tête vous gagnerez
encore plus puisque vous gagnerez 25000
francs ce soir
on a repéré des gens encore plus
bizarres comme par exemple Tanguy de
gens ce que je vous demande d'accueillir
dans cette émission
pouvez-vous mettre un tout petit peu de
profil voilà qu'est-ce qui comme ça vous
avez un truc qui pend à l'oreille c'est
quoi une boucle une boucle c'est bizarre
une boucle orange un jeune homme et la
cuisine
quoi je vois pas des très bien
la vie vous avez bien la croix
vous êtes étudiant tourisme enfin
bientôt en tourisme en vacances
je sais pas encore essayé d'accord bonne
chance en tout cas j'espère que vous
ferez et du tourisme des vacances d'ici
la fin de cette émission Chantal Richer
favorite également dans l'émission
ah bah oui
on choisit pas toujours c'est vraiment
la tête du client des fois au moyen des
gens comme ça qui me vous êtes
technicienne d'analyse biologique
c'est exact c'est passionnant ou c'était
passionnant
donc la première année c'était bien mais
les 15 ans qui suivent
ça devient toujours un peu un peu alors
vous prenez un train de banlieue pour
rentrer chez vous régulièrement et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé un jour j'ai
levé les bras
tout simplement
la jupe au pied à mes pieds
est également là également
Christian vous êtes de quelle région
venez-vous de Rochefort-sur-Mer pour
nous oui ça ça me touche
bouleversé
vraiment je suis très touché ça m'étonne
pas vraiment et vous avez rencontré une
grande star il y a très longtemps oui
mais quand même une grande star toujours
tout à fait c'était Catherine Deneuve à
Rochefort
oui ça ça devient un peu lourd on
l'avait déjà dit ça il fallait pas la
peine de il est en pleine forme
Christian on va voir la suite Isabelle
fedo
toute ma vie j'ai rêvé d'être une
Isabelle Feydeau puisque vous êtes
hôtesse
pour le moment chez eux
vers d'autres cieux d'accord et ben
voilà ça fait office de démission là si
vous voulez au lieu vous enverrez la
cassettes de l'émission ce sera plus
clair il le prendront mieux ils auront
eu un petit coup de pub et une démission
en même temps cadeau d'accord bonne
chance Isabelle bonne chance aux 200
candidats aussi la première question je
ne dis rien puisque c'est encore plus
difficile regardez écoutez surtout
[Musique]
je vous avais dit que c'était dur
ils sont gentils vas-y la question cette
musique est tirée de quoi être réponses
10 secondes s Speedy Gonzalez Woody
Woodpecker Saturn ou Hugues Sidonie
à tous les enfants qui sautent
au revoir
et vous m'aidez Woody Woodpecker en
majorité
[Applaudissements]
deuxième question 193 voici quel est le
nom du mouvement que lança Andy Warhol
dans les années 60-4 mouvements et 10
secondes était le peuple art le pop rock
le power pop ou le pop-corn
[Musique]
il y a doré aussi les boîtes de conserve
de soupe de tomates
et vous me dites
on a un pop-corn quand même dans la
salle
alors je m'adresse particulièrement
pop-corn 2 secondes j'arrive mais dans
l'immédiat pop art c'est la bonne
réponse
alors avant d'arriver au pop-corn
Chantal
en moyenne vous mettez combien de temps
quand on vous dit 10 secondes pour vous
ça représente 15 20 30 40 secondes
vous avez parlé dans les 10 secondes
j'ai pas répondu ben non et qu'est-ce
que vous avez répondu
[Musique]
bon en tout cas vous avez pas vous
n'êtes pas dans les 10 secondes je suis
désolé
et vous avez pas en plus discuter les
yeux c'est la première fois qu'on est là
à 19h15 on va pas commencer par un
scandale donc voilà donc on dit qu'on se
revoit bientôt machin midi le soir quand
vous voulez d'accord merci Merci à VOUS
surtout d'être venu et alors le pop-corn
il est où le popcorn
Pascal Ribeiro
enfin Pascal ce cher Pascal Ribeiro en
pleine forme bien alors donc nous avions
pop rock power pop qui pouvait être
encore léger doute mais alors le
pop-corn vous êtes pas dit que c'était
louche
vous pouvez me faire des signes si vous
voulez pas parler
bah oui je me suis trompé
déjà on pense la même chose ce qui est
bien parce qu'on pouvait pas être
d'accord faites quoi dans la vie je suis
encore au lycée
première vous êtes en première c'est un
premier embrayage pour passer
non d'accord à bientôt Pascal merci de
votre visite aussi la troisième question
pour les 157 candidats en cours c'est
nous n'avons plus que trois personnes
que j'allais repérer au début on va voir
comment ça va durer regardez ces images
d'abord
ça énerve largement d'ailleurs la sono
ce feu la RATP et tout ce qui se passe
au niveau peinture mais c'est un art
vraiment comment appelle-t-on ces
dessins quatre réponses 10 secondes sont
des raps des tags des rames ou des dames
[Musique]
raptagram bling bling 157 et quel talent
c'est vrai qu'on avait dit que les
missions des questions plus dures mais
on avait oublié de préciser que les
candidats seraient plus brillants
et que l'animateur sera encore plus
hypocrite
très dur 157 lequel de ces quatre hommes
fut président de la République française
1 channel de Deschanel 3 béchamel 4
bonnes
de plus en plus dur
[Musique]
je croyez qu'il y aura un béchamel dans
la salle
je m'attends pire lors du repas proche
on sait jamais voyons vos réponses
quand même
des Chanel oui 135 bonnes raisons
et aux trois béchamel
j'ai une petite histoire sur la béchamel
je vous raconterai un tout petit peu
plus tard j'ai vraiment pas le temps
c'est normal cinquième question d'image
regardez
il faut pousser au démarrage parce que
ça démarre pas tout seul
et le magnéto et le char à voile
d'ailleurs
dérapages contrôlés alors
j'ai dit
non je l'ai pas dit j'ai dit non non
j'ai pas dit
bon
j'avais pas dit d'accord ils sont 135
quand même ceux qui ont entendu ce que
j'ai dit voici la question de quoi
s'agit-il donc 4 réponses 10 secondes 1
Charles d'assaut de charabans trois
chars à voile 4 charlatans
[Musique]
ils sont plus bruyants on va pas quand
même douter un dixième de seconde
évidemment 135 bonne réponse Ciao
non seulement je ne dirai rien je ne
pose même pas la question suivante comme
ça j'ai vite toute gaffe 135 à me dire
quelle était l'instrument de
prédilection d'art atomes 4 réponses
seconde
trompette piano batterie saxophone alors
on fait moins les malins
trompette de piano trois batteries 4
saxophone
jazz américain oui mais à quel
instrument
ouais c'est un mec va
vraiment
il touchait à tout normalement quand il
y a autant de divisions au sein du
public la majorité à raison et là
laissez-moi vous dire que la majorité
comme d'habitude
a tort puisqu'il y a 21 ans de réponse
il était au piano
je précise quand même qu'il y en a 114
qui viennent de perdre sur cette
question 114 ils étaient contents pour
le char à voile mais
Tanguy
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
le côté de Tatum
à bientôt oui
le jazz normalement parce que demoiselle
de Rochefort c'est un peu jazzy tout à
fait tout à fait tout à fait anagui nous
on vous entendez c'est pas grave on vous
entendez avec la perche mais quand je
pense que de l'autre côté on a fait
écorché le visage une ravissante de
personnes je suis mis des Elisa on
trouvera nos systèmes ça va vous avez
pas eu peur un peu quand même légèrement
décoiffé et puis Isabelle Feydeau
notre hôtesse de l'air derrière liberté
qui a donc présenté sa démission
officiellement aujourd'hui
vous vous m'avez rien dit vous n'êtes
même pas répondu à 10 secondes ah bon
vous avez pas la musique
trop tard apparemment en plus donc vous
auriez eu faux même si vous étiez c'est
pas grave mais merci d'avoir été honnête
en tout cas à bientôt Isabelle
7e question seulement 21 candidats je
vous demande un petit service si vous
pouvez rester juste 10 pour la deuxième
manche énormément pour pour l'émission
merci voici la question en images
regardez
voici donc la tour de Pise où se trouve
la tour de Pise
[Applaudissements]
jamais de la vie jamais de la vie la
ville de Pise se trouve dans quelle
région quatre régions italiennes disent
seconde Moïse Calabre Lombardie au
Toscane
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
21 candidats
et voyons vos réponses sur ces 21 la
Toscane
alors 17 et quoi qu'il arrive quoi qu'il
arrive vous quoi qu'il arrive vous serez
donc 10 à la fin de cette question car
nous allons garder les 10 plus rapides
les 10 plus rapides et ensuite garderont
les deux meilleurs et ensuite je vous le
rappelle voyage encore plus loin encore
plus beau encore plus au soleil et 25000
francs à la fin de cette émission donc
il est important pour vous d'être dans
les 10 plus rapides voici la question
quel nom ne désigne pas un mousquetaire
du célèbre roman de Dumas voici les
quatre mousquetaires proposés 10
secondes Aramis portos artiste ou Atos
[Musique]
on a dû mettre Arte moi ça m'a fait
plaisir
[Musique]
juste pour moi alors voyons vos réponses
je pense que ça devrait aller
oui alors Porto déjà
Patrick on oublie mais sinon les la
bonne réponse bien sûr c'est artiste dit
bonne réponse c'est ce qu'il me faut
un truc il me faut 10 sur les 14 que
nous avons eu alors nous allons garder
les 10 plus rapides voici les noms des
candidats pour la deuxième manche il y a
François Meunier
Françoise bras de taille
Benoît Blazy
Mireille Salaunes
à la zaventki
Richard Magali
Hervé
Daniel Bravo
Vincent perche et Béatrice Faucheux
voilà des candidats pour une place au
soleil et 25000 francs nous nous
retrouvons après ça
donc la deuxième manche avec je vous
demande de l'applaudir Mireille saloon
bonjour Mireille
maman au foyer oui enfin disons
maintenant je suis même un tout petit
peu retraité un tout petit retrait de
complémentaire avec un petit accent qui
vient d'où Marseille ah bien et là vous
venez de demain
l'accent du monde
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir pardon bonsoir bonsoir Françoise
que faites-vous dans la vie
j'aimerais bien être comme vous ça prend
beaucoup de temps et vous faites des
gâteaux vous faites des confitures
Richard Magali bonsoir
comédien oui dans quel domaine ben
justement ce moment je passe pas
beaucoup à la télé alors j'en ai profité
et là vous êtes un ordre de grande
écoute
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure en cas de
victoire et 25000 francs
votre chat tourne il a tourné votre chat
attende
et c'était pourquoi happy end un
téléfilm qui va passer au mois de
septembre ah d'accord et votre chat
s'appelle
pussy oui
bonsoir Daniel
vous avez une
vous avez une côte en plus ou moins en
plus normalement
au début de l'histoire c'était quand
même on a enlevé une côte pour pour la
file à l'autre là non j'ai bien suivi
l'histoire quand même non et bah vous
non vous en avez en plus d'accord vous
en faites commerces ou c'est juste pour
vous
et ça sert à rien même pas en boîte le
soir bonsoir J'ai une côte de plus non
bon dommage Benoît blasé que bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes monté en navette spatiale
en Floride
ça doit être beau de faire un voyage en
Floride c'est pas mal c'est comment la
Floride
géant
et vous êtes monté dans la navette
spatiale mais il y en a une qui est en
exposition et donc on pouvait monter à
l'intérieur c'était fait ils avaient
oublié la clé donc vous avez pas pu
Vincent perche bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes donc dans la vie que ah oui on
dit plus flic on dit que maintenant
voilà c'est donc un flic branché que
nous avons ce soir Béatrice fauche
bonsoir Béatrice
vous avez un bronzage sublime vraiment
super le temps génial caillou fait
pendant 12 mois
d'aoûté d'accord vous allez parfaire
votre bronzage d'accord elle était allée
sur le retour donc bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
agent d'assurance assez accessoires
assez accessoires pour vous mais surtout
que il tient de pin's oui chaque fois
que je croise
d'ailleurs je voulais faire un petit
message si vous me croisez je n'ai pas
de pin's donc Alain ne me demandez plus
de pin's je déteste j'en ai marre des
villes tout le monde veut des piles je
n'en ai pas des piles voilà agenda
d'assurance je n'ai pas d'assurance non
plus voilà François Meunier
c'est entre nous avec Alain j'avais
prévenu que je j'attaquerai un peu donc
tout va bien alors François que
faites-vous ben je suis prof de physique
ça peut arriver en quelle classe en
collège en collège secondaire
encore ah peut-être pas pour longtemps
mais
pas quand j'étais en tout cas
vous avez raté
nous allons garder les deux les deux qui
se qui sortiront victorieux de cette
manche aussi la première question en
images regardez
[Musique]
nous sommes là dans les Landes dans
l'éclairage public et la question est de
savoir quel est l'inventeur de la lampe
à incandescence 4 inventeurs et 10
secondes Benjamin Franklin de Thomas
Edison 3 gel 4 James Watt
[Musique]
en tout cas il en a fait des trucs lui
alors voyons voyons votre réponse faut
répondre
ah
je peux déjà vous dire qu'il y a 5
bonnes réponses
c'est un petit indice comme ça juste
pour vous aiguiller vous qui jouer chez
vous et ce sont les cinq qui m'ont
répondu Thomas Edison la bonne réponse
bien écoutez Béatrice je vais vous
laisser sous votre lampe à bronzée à
bientôt au revoir Alain sans rancune
hein finalement je vais peut-être vous
trouver un pin quand même pour vous
donc vous êtes professeur de français
François vous êtes en vacances vous avez
le droit
Daniel et Hervé à bientôt également 5
pépites s'éteignent
et cinq candidats restent en course pour
la deuxième question je vous demande
quel cycliste n'a jamais remporté le
Tour de France c'est facile quatre
réponses 10 secondes
[Musique]
petit indice quand même il était souvent
deuxième
[Musique]
alors vos réponses 5 à jouer
bon alors Richard
la bonne réponse 4 bonnes réponses
au revoir Richard à bientôt et bonne
route dans votre difficile métier de
comédien voici la troisième question
illustrée
[Musique]
ambiance jazzy avec ce son bien
particulier la sourdine du trompette se
fixe dans quoi 80 réponses se fixe dans
la coulisse l'embouchure le piston ou le
pavillon
[Musique]
et vous me dites
tout au bout au Pavillon oui
[Applaudissements]
Mireille Françoise Benoit et Vincent
sont encore en cours c'est quoi qu'il
arrive nous garderons les deux plus
rapides les deux plus rapides qui vont
répondre correctement bien sûr à la
question que voici attention rapidité et
correction sont exigées quel était le
prénom de Bugatti 4 prénoms 10 secondes
1 Victorio 3 étoile 2 pardon étoile 3
Giacomo et 4 Oscar
invitorio 2 étoile trois Giacomo 4 Oscar
4 à jouer vos réponses Bugatti est Torré
oui
[Applaudissements]
bon en 1947 et c'est l'un des
précurseurs au sein constructeurs
automobiles alors nous avons tous les
noms de nos bons candidats quand même
s'ils sont très bruyants depuis le début
ils ont toujours répondu correctement et
c'est Benoît et Muret
on va Mireille
Françoise désolé Vincent à très bientôt
je le souhaite en tout cas c'est donc
soit Mireille soit Benoît je trouverai
soit Benoît je préfère qu'il soit bien
et qui va gagner tout à l'heure non
Benoît je plaisante je vous taquine un
peu quoi que je préfère que ce soit bien
enfin moi
en tout cas se disputer et le voyage et
bien sûr l'accession ensuite au 25000
francs nous revenons tout de suite après
que Jean-Luc vous expliquer comment vous
inscrire à l'émission que ce soit que le
meilleur gagne à 12h30 ou que le
meilleur gagne plus à 19h15 il suffit de
s'inscrire à écouter
écrivez-nous à que le meilleur gagne
c'est d'ex 39-50
99395 Paris concours en joignant une
enveloppe timbrée libellée à vos noms et
adresses ou plus simplement parmi d'elle
en tapant 36 15 codes à deux
alors bien sûr pour vous inscrire dans
quelques instants même tout de suite
d'ailleurs nous attaquons cette
troisième manche opposant Mireille salin
je veux bien prononcer à Benoît Blazy je
veux bien prononcer je l'ai bien fait
oui c'est bien fait pour vous Benoit
contre Mireille Mireille contre Benoît
une série de questions chaque fois que
vous répondez correctement sans aucun
problème de chronomètre dans un premier
temps vous inscrirez à chaque bonne
réponse bien sûr un point la première
personne ayant atteint les trois points
gagnent le voyage merveilleux voyage une
semaine au soleil et la possibilité
surtout de jouer pour les 25000 francs
si jamais vous êtes à égalité au stade
de deux trois points à ce moment là il y
aura une question de rapidité Mireille
est-ce claire tout à fait
aussi aussi bien sans perdre une seule
seconde voici la première question la
locution
IDS signifie 4 possibilités 10 secondes
premièrement de même de deuxièmement
c'est-à-dire 3 à la fin 4 il en est
ainsi
[Musique]
il en est ainsi c'est ita est qui m'a
dit vous m'avez dit ça
vous allez le perdre sur ce coup-là
encore plus ça veut dire c'est à dire et
c'est Benoît qui inscrit le premier
point
[Applaudissements]
deuxième question il reste très
concentré deuxième question si je fête
mon anniversaire le 2 janvier quel est
mon signe zodiaque 4 signes 10 secondes
un verseau de Capricorne 3 Sagittaire 4
bélier
[Musique]
voyons une réponse Mireille Benoît
Capricorne oui c'est la bonne réponse
tous les deux vous inscrivez un point
le score et de 2 pour Benoît 1 pour
Mireille Mireille bah oui c'est bien la
solution maintenant c'est que Benoît
chute sur cette question Benoît si vous
répondez correctement c'est le voyage
qui est dans votre poche
en quelle année c'est la troisième
question peut-être déterminante en
quelle année est né le loto national 4
années proposées 10 secondes était-ce en
45 en 68 en 76 ou en 80
on ne souffle pas s'il vous plaît en jeu
et de taille
fin du chronomètre tout va se jouer sur
cette réponse sans doute
voyons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la bonne réponse et c'est donc
Benoît qui gagne le voyage
alors Mireille
merci une seule erreur depuis le début
vous a répondu toujours correctement
toujours rapidement
je vous embrasse on la folie très fort
s'il vous plaît Mireille
[Applaudissements]
avec nous restez avec nous parce que
tout à l'heure vous allez pouvoir jouer
parce que il est important de préciser
que non seulement Benoît a gagné un
voyage et dans quelques instants Benoît
je pense vous allez être séduit par la
destination que vous avez remporté à
l'instant mais tout à l'heure vous allez
pouvoir jouer pour 25000 francs seul
face au 199 candidats dont Mireille
d'ailleurs et si vous répondez
correctement ils seront pour vous sinon
ça sera bien sûr les bonnes réponses en
public qui se partageront ces 25000
francs Benoît on a parlé tout à l'heure
d'un endroit dans le monde regardez le
voyage que vous venez de gagner au
soleil
la Floride vous attend pour une semaine
au Club Med de Sean piper la mer la
détente et le sport vous attendent pour
un séjour enchanteur à deux pas des
parcs d'attraction de Walt Disney le
bonheur si vous voulez à vivre à deux
super
heureux
prof de maths je le rappelle et donc
vous étiez amoureux de la Floride j'ai
découvert ce pays
en plus gratos
et la princesse c'est Antenne 2 en
l'occurrence bien attention maintenant
l'instant est grave une question 4
éléments de réponse à réordonner
25000 francs sont en jeu je vais pas
être méchant mais si les profs étaient
peut-être un peu mieux payés ça irait
peut-être mieux donc 25000 francs c'est
costaud merci c'est très important non
le message est passé en tout cas 25000
francs en jeu si vous répondez
correctement Benoît les 25000 francs
sont bien sûr pour vous en plus du
voyage sinon vous gardez toujours votre
voyage et ce sont les bonnes réponses
dans le public qui se partageront ces
25000 francs attention vous avez 15
secondes vous publique pour répondre et
quant à vous Benoît pour réfléchir bonne
chance Benoît voici la question c'est
l'histoire pour un prof de maths
c'est pas donné mais on sait jamais je
vous demande de classer donc ces
présidents de la République française
dans l'ordre chronologique de leur
mandat du plus ancien plus récent quatre
présidents de la République et qu'un
second de réflexion 1 Jules Grévy 2
Emilie Loubet 3 sady Carnot 4 Félix Ford
10 secondes encore
fin du chronomètre public a répondu et
maintenant nous allons nous intéresser à
votre réponse Benoît
alors deux Émile Loubet de Emile Loubet
un Jules Grévy un Jules Grévy 1 4 Félix
Faure 4 Félix Faure et 3 Sadi Carnot et
3 ça dit Carnot nous affichons votre
réponse comment vous le sentez du hasard
le pur hasard vraiment vraiment le pur
hasard bien on va voir ce que donne le
hasard nous affichons notre réponse
Émile Loubet je lui avais Félix Faure et
Sadi Carnot on est d'accord Benoît nous
allons comparer votre réponse avec la
solution idéale 25000 francs sont en jeu
vous m'avez d'abord dit Émile Loubet de
1899 à 1906 et il y avait je rêvais
d'abord Sadi Carnot Félix Faure et Emile
Loubet en fait vous avez inversé pas mal
pas mal de présentes de la République
sur ce coup-là mais Benoît vous gardez
bien sûr votre voyage pour deux en
Floride s'il vous plaît
attention
vous êtes exactement 11 à avoir donné la
bonne réponse à vous partager les 25000
francs
2272 francs et 72 cl bien sûr Benoît
garçon voyage en Floride vous également
l'applaudir pendant une semaine au
soleil
on se donne rendez-vous demain à 12h30
et à 19h15 pour que le meilleur gagne
plus et on va applaudir et accueillir
les 11 gagnants il y a de Niger en
couple dire Thierry cornet Thierry
Mallard Majorie Thomas venez avec moi
venez venez Hervé dimonet Hélène d'Ella
Christophe Chopin Claude Chopin
Jean-François Thibault Martin Philippe
et à la Vigny voilà bravo ce sont nos
gagnants du jour avec bien sûr Benoît
basique passé une très bonne soirée sur
Antenne 2 à demain bye bye bonne soirée
et c'est avec nous
[Musique]